Patrick back to throw dolphins Radio
Network the Dolphins team MVP for 2019
Ryan Fitzpatrick
three seven years old love and life may
be back next year with the team getting
it done and spoiling the Patriots
opportunity to be the number two seed in
the AFC what a shocker that was you
tased a Patriots loss you combine it
with the Chiefs win 31 to 21 over the
Chargers and the Kansas City Chiefs
after we all forgot about them after the
Pat mahomes injury and the defense
really isn't any better until it was
better and there are the Chiefs as the
number two seed obviously the Ravens
they were the ones who were locked in as
were the bills at number five the rest
was TBD going into week 17 Chiefs it to
Patriots fall to three the Texans are
locked in now at four they will play
Saturday 4:35 p.m. Eastern in the slot
Masjid and Zurich they should call the
nation times the Houston attacking game
a Memorial playoff spot they'll host the
bills and then Saturday night both AFC
games on Saturday Saturday night
the Titans at the Patriots the AFC field
is set and and look the Ravens are cut
above but you still got to go out and
win your games yeah and who knows who
they're gonna see as that playoff
picture unfolds ya know I know I mean
they're they're clearly are a cut above
I you know I want to say they are a cut
above but I don't think by much and then
of course this is a sport of matchups
where I look at the Kansas City Chiefs
and still say they're gonna have
something to say about this one all said
and done and if they play Baltimore
Ravens what you know in being Baltimore
that'll be dangerous that'll be a 50/50
game to me but you know I think the the
first thing and I know I said this
earlier in the show where hey I'm pumped
that we got the six best teams in the
AFC in the playoffs I certainly think
the Titans were the
team the way they've played down the
stretch very impressive and it leads us
to some really interesting matchups you
know I mean again you just yeah okay
Ravens Chiefs sitting at home Chiefs got
to win one home game and then maybe go
on the road maybe they stay home who
knows what happens but um yeah I I don't
know why I just have a feeling it's the
Chiefs year I I don't know why I feel
that way like I almost wanted let's do
what we did with the NFC I want early
lean Mike Florio okay like that's what I
want to do I want to go
first off let's go to the Houston
Memorial first wild card game who do you
like they're really Exxon's yeah bills
you do you like to build like that's my
early lean yeah not my final pick yeah
hand is not off the checker yeah King me
not yet right but I'll take the bills is
will full we're gonna be playing do we
know that yeah no so that that's that's
an issue but I'm with you I think my
early lean is the Buffalo Bills to
defense play is good they can run the
ball and the pass game is good enough to
take advantage of a questionable
secondary for the Houston Texans alright
the other one you know tight sage it's
very early lean I know you're not making
a pick I know I'm not making a pick and
I'm gonna repeat what I've said
throughout the last two and a half hours
my three and a half hours if we count
the hour that I was here and you weren't
yeah the Patriots are the Terminator and
the Terminator is not dead until that
metal body is completely dismembered
melted down and the individual vials of
molten steel are shipped to locations
throughout the globe or elsewhere in the
solar system even then you cannot
pronounce the Terminator dead yeah the
Patriots are the Terminator and I will
not pronounce them dead my early lean is
mooing yeah I I think my early lean is
Tennessee it is I think Tennessee's
through the last five weeks just a
better football to you're stepping right
into it here I know you're turning your
back I know oh I love broken parts do
you think is dead yeah and it's gonna
reconstitute and it's gonna stick a
sword right through your spleen yeah
well I mean you're you're yeah my some
other some that I had where your spleen
was used to be that space there that's
yes but yeah I don't know I just say I
worry about the Patriots offense and I
know the Titans defense you
their weakness to their defense is past
defense and guess what the Patriots
aren't that good at passing the ball so
and then of course they have balance on
the offensive side of the ball so by
aurélie leanest tightens their butt now
okay so we go to the next round you're
gonna have Ravens Bill's right
Ravens bills your next round what's your
real early lien on Ravens bill
Ravens bills if that's how it plays out
my lean is Ravens right my lien is not
that's the way oh wait yeah it won't
play out that way the way you're talking
about it right now
you're white right you're right you're
at Ravens berline it's Titans right
Raven I'm going Ravens as well either
whether it's the bills or the Titans I'm
going with the Ravens to win that game
see I worry about the Ravens against the
Titans far more than I worry about the
Ravens against the bills far more yeah I
get that I think it's a well yeah
because the tannenhill has some weapons
at its disposal in the past game and
they have you know arguably the best
running back in football so the other I
get you there that's definitely a
scarier matchup all right for your lien
with the second round you would have the
Chiefs Patriots real early where are you
gonna lean there as you're texting
somebody on the computer I'm not yeah
play it off no no I'm not gonna play I'm
still not ready to say the Terminator is
dead I can't declare the Terminator dead
you're gonna take the Patriots early
lean two weeks out to beat the Chiefs in
Kansas City Patriots over the Chiefs my
early lean is the Patriots would go that
pagers this team we saw yesterday
maybe that's where it ends maybe it ends
in Kansas City I agree with you my early
lean is Chiefs over page okay all right
and then you know Ravens Chiefs if that
happened what are you gonna go there
Ravens Chiefs are probably Ravens but I
don't know because I agree with you
maybe the Chiefs year maybe cheese
without Chiefs really Niners Super Bowl
yeah well that's what's you know I think
I'm hoping for Niner Saints Chiefs
Ravens cuz I think that gives us a great
Super Bowl that's what I'm rooting for
and I'll just with my point but did the
Chiefs where I think they match up with
the Ravens Ravens want to get in your
face they want a blitz they want to play
man-to-man they want to do those so
think that's dangerous to do against
Patrick mahomes and Tyree kill and Sammy
Watkins and Travis
see you just can't get in the face of
those guys play after play after play
and think your DBS are gonna win on an
island like that so that's scary and the
Chiefs can pass protect so those are two
things I look at right away they go ooh
that scares me about that great Ravens
defense and then the other side of the
ball the Chiefs have sized up front I
don't think they're gonna get like
steamrolled by that Ravens offensive
line now can the Ravens throw the ball
on that chief secondary that'll probably
be really what to term is a football
game when also Thornhill Chiefs
defensive back is out oh that's big that
really is he's have been a really
effective rookie out of Virginia I want
to say he was a second maybe a
third-round pick but he's done a really
nice job for them and that that's a big
blow to their football team
you know the Chiefs have handled the
Ravens well but in Baltimore the idea of
a Chiefs 49ers Super Bowl is fascinating
it is it really is yeah he's got one of
the youngest coach in the NFL one of the
oldest coaches in the NFL Andy Reed the
idea that you know he's he desert you
know there's this sense he deserves it
yeah some point he deserves a Super Bowl
championship and and you just wonder
whether or not he would call it quit if
you get the top two seeds in each con
it's not the top two seeds yeah I worry
about the Packers ruining the Super Bowl
that's what I worry about the Baltimore
Ravens they're gonna get blown out this
is the 49ers along the way 49 that's why
I want Saints Niners and ravens cheese
because then we're assured of a good
Super Bowl
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports